I had this move called the Russian death
lock that I used to throw on my friends
Sean can you come here I'm going to put
the Russian death lock on you so it was
basically like a full nelson it wasn't
anything bad but what I realized was
there was like this hook within here so
I'd go here and if I would lock oh there
we go I heard that crack if I would lock
what do you think yeah does it hurts
so where's the HR department
yeah it hurt it was it was great so the
Russian death lock was a big big move
and a lot of people would tap on that
move it's a good hole right it worked
yeah where does it hurt the shoulders
yeah and uh ego a little bit